- [Mark] Tiffany, where
are you from originally?
- Kansas, Wichita, Kansas
- [Mark] Wichita, Kansas.
And how long have you
been here at skid row?
- [Tiffany] About 16 years.
- [Mark] 16 years, do you have children?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How old are the kids?
- Like? I don't know.
Three, I don't know how old
my two youngest boys are up there.
They're adopting the same family,
but I had one like five years
ago, one like seven years ago.
So, you do the math
and then I have a 14-year old, I guess,
and a 10-year old and a 23,
22-year old and a 17-year old.
- [Mark] And do you talk to any of them?
- Yeah, but now my two youngest boys.
- [Mark] And they're
all back in, you can't?
- No, well, my kids are about my, well,
actually the two boys I
don't know where they are,
but they ended up in this.
They got one guy when I had them,
my first,
when I had my kids out here,
my parents adopted them.
Yeah, they thought that
I was state's custody.
They were going to be took,
cause I had done drugs with them.
And so my parents ended up with my kids
except for the last two boys.
They didn't, they were
already raising my daughter.
She just graduated college.
- [Mark] So, tell me what
happened to your teeth.
I photographed you before, years ago.
- When I had beautiful teeth, yeah, huh.
Anyways, how many years ago was that?
- [Mark] It was probably about
four, maybe five years ago.
- My boyfriend and me, we got
in a fight because I came home
and there was a girl in the tent
and, anyways, he was suffocating
me and I couldn't breathe.
So, I was yanking on his balls
and his dick, pinching him
and he just started punching shit on me.
- [Mark] And he hit you in the mouth?
- [Tiffany] in the jaw
several times, really hard.
My face was out to here.
- [Mark] So, you lost a couple of ...
- [Tiffany] Like knocked out my tooth.
And then another one was like
half knocked out and half in,
and so I ripped it out.
That tooth right here,
that's like that long.
I was like, wow.
But anyways, and then
like, as time would go by,
one tooth would fall out, and
another tooth would fall out.
- [Mark] Let me see what you have left.
Wow.
- I mean, I had like
seven of them pulled out
while I was in jail, you know,
up in the back and stuff,
but all this right here has
got, you know, important shit.
- [Mark] So, yeah, how many
times have you been in jail?
- I can't even count, but
it was all for stupid shit.
Only serious time was
when I went to the feds.
- [Mark] Only what?
- When I went to the feds.
I did time, got out, violated,
went back and then served my time.
And I'm always going in
for dumb shit, you know,
Letting tickets end up into a warrant
and it was for possession
with the intent to distribute.
- [Mark] How was?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What is your drug of choice?
- Heroin.
- [ Mark] Heroin.
- Unfortunately.
- [Mark] At what age did you
start doing drugs, period,
whether it was pot or alcohol or whatever?
- 13
17 for some things
So, I really using when I was 17, cocaine
But, first time I ever tried
any, is that what you mean?
- [Mark] Yeah.
I'm, like, I don't know, nine.
Drank my first beer, drank my first beer,
I think I was nine or 10.
- [Mark] Wow.
Show me what happened to your arm.
- You want to see it raw?
- [Mark] I don't know if I can handle it.
- No, it's just that I, fucking,
it's just I had abscesses.
Like, you see these dots right here.
I had the same thing and
my arm was swelling up.
And so I put hot water on it
and it all brought all
the pus to the head.
And then I was able to lance it, myself.
Because my doctor was, when
she was going to drain it,
She nicked an artery.
So, she had to stop and
put staples in there
and she wanted to take me
to the hospital in Torrence,
but I was like, no.
So, I drained it myself,
but if I would've known what I do now.
- [Mark] Can you turn it so I can see?
Wow, that's really ...
- It dried up on me back here
and like this one right
here, that's an abscess
from muscling that I, I
cut it open a little bit,
so she could get the rest out.
I'm not that brave to cut myself.
And it's not like big enough to where,
powerful enough to where it would,
like, break a hole in your skin
- [Mark] Wow, was it painful?
- Not anymore.
Well, this thing not like it was,
I didn't even know I had it
until the other day I was poking on it.
So I was like, okay.
So I took a needle top and just drained it
and, yeah, it was
already coming to a head.
I should've put heat on it more
and it would piped up more.
- [Mark] So how are you
making money tonight?
Are you picking up guys?
- Not really, but I won't turn them down,
but I probably, will too.
It depends on who it is.
Why, you want a date?
I give massages, too, not just that.
- [Mark] I'll bet they're good.
- Yeah, I wish I could rub my own back.
- [Mark] What a
What you do you see happening
in the next five years for you?
Where would you like to be?
- Have my keys and my own place.
And, hopefully, with my boyfriend
if he would just like find his mind,
but I know that it won't be true,
but just not beat up anymore.
And off this shit.
- [Mark] How many times
has he been violent?
- [Tiffany] He's always violent.
See, crystal meth just
fucks him up, really bad.
He was threatening to kill
himself the other day.
He wanted to take me with him to Compton,
but, I've already been to
his people's house, you know.
And he calls my kids, his,
and his kids say that they're mine
and our grandchildren and shit
and I've met the family
and they all say he loves you and stuff.
I'm like, he's really a
God-fearing Christian and stuff,
but he's really cruel to me.
Blames stuff on me,
everything, everything.
- [Mark] How long have
you guys been together?
- [Patricia] About, like I
must have started dating him
after I did that photography with you.
I just realized that.
Yeah.
And it was like about two
years into the relationship
when my teeth got knocked out.
- [Mark] So the heroin,
have you ever OD'd before?
- [Patricia] Yeah, on purpose.
Yeah, cause my cat got ran over and killed
when I was in jail and I was devastated.
I need a bandage.
- [Mark] When you were a
child, were you, I mean,
what was your childhood like?
- My parents, when I was, my
mom gave me up for adoption,
like, me and my brother, you know?
And she chose a Mexican
over us, this wetback
and he told her three weeks
after she signed the
private adoption papers
that she might as well think
of us little bastards as dead,
cause she'd never see us again.
What a creep, huh?
He wanted her to marry him.
He's Mexican.
They had three kids or I'm
sorry, two kids, no, three kids,
three kids, I'm bad.
- [Mark] So, you ended up where?
- Me and my brother ended
up in an adopted family.
That was okay, but the
mother died from cancer
and the man was a trash man.
He worked with a trash company
and he ended up remarrying
this psycho bitch,
that would ... abusing us, molesting us
and they ended up killing him
and staging it as a suicide,
all for his life insurance money.
It was horrible.
We got molested and abused.
She was just an Oprah show, anyway.
I really got to get back to my laundry.
- [Mark] Alright, I'll let you go.
Thank you for sharing your story.
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
I don't want to rush it though,
cause you're paying me 20 bucks.
So, if there's anything more.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- [Patricia] I don't want
to, I mean, I can wait.
- [Mark] No, no, no, it's all good.
- Alright, thank you.
It was good seeing you again.
- [Mark] Nice to see you again.
- What was your name?
- [Mark] Mark
- Mark, cool, awesome.
- [Mark] Alright, well, be safe out there.
- This is your brain.
This is your brain on
drugs, any questions.
Yeah, and I got another
one on the other side
that you could check out.
- [Mark] Another what, abscess?
- that's open.
No, it's not.
- [Mark] Let me see it.
Okay.
She opened it and lanced it, yeah.
- [Mark] Nice.
- Now let me show you what it looks like,
Whenever it's going and
before it's lanced right.
I'm not taking them down
any further than that
but I'm pretty sure that somebody
that it busted when I was,
by being slapped because
it just like started, like,
like, just going down
all of a sudden, right?
And I think there was
some leakage a little bit.
So, that's probably possible, huh?
- [Mark] Absolutely.
- So, when it got slapped,
it was, like, fucking hard.
Like three ...
- [Mark] There's a lot of shit
going on with you, darling.
- Yeah, but does it look like a spot
where it could have been opened?
Cause I want to so badly draw it out
- [Mark] The stuff down on your ass
is not nearly as bad as what
I'm seeing on your shoulder.
- Oh, right, right, right, right, right.
- Yeah, see, I did have stretch marks.